huacho l effort le connais singh du
premier album solo de luan ses vanités
notre invité ce soir clip de francis
lawrence dans un esprit très alice au
pays des merveilles et cash veux que me
suis un petit peu caressé pendant
l'année le clip en gwen stefani avait
génial car il a compris la table sa
french tribu jeunes viennent
à montmirat qu'une flamme
la
discussion
the world skies yabulu au nom des lois
elle et elle est formidable c'est super
mais tous ses clips sont magnifiques la
nouvelle grande star mondiale on est
très heureux de vous avoir mais ces
personnes derrière elle qui sont très
inquiétantes quand même un espoir
oui c'est vous faites quoi
c'est mon rêve en fait je suis étonné
que vous arrivez à vous les voyez ce job
c'est mon fantasme c'est un rêve j'étais
pas au courant vous laisse
ce week end si jack kirby
comment tu la trouves gwen stefani
guillaud a jugé complètement moi je suis
fan depuis très longtemps ouais j'adore
sa voix j'adore ces clips j'adore on a
tout sauvé dans les aigus
non
5 je suis un comics jim popp
je suis le comique le plus vulgaire 40
s'échange à petit son job
ch
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux